we're living on the cusp of the new
media age actually we're already deep
into it and when scholars can tear their
eyes away from the computer screen
they've looked back upon the history of
the book
now for jews no book has figured more
centrally
more profoundly in their history than
the bible
the jewish bible by the phrase the
jewish bible i mean the hebrew bible
that jews have actually held in their
hands and used not the text but the
physical object
whether it's been a scroll like the
monumental torah scroll or a book in the
course of history the material features
of these scrolls and books have changed
dramatically jews have developed laws
and rituals around them the objects
themselves come to possess their own
symbolic meaning this course requires no
previous background in jewish history or
judaism but it will take you on a tour
of jewish history from the ancient
period down until today
this course will teach you about many
things about the bible about judaism and
jewish history about jews christians and
muslims and how they've interacted but
more than anything else it will teach
you that a book is more than just words
on a page that has an object it has a
life of its own that is worth pondering
and understanding
[Music]